OF CIVIL LIBERTIES.
>> Laura: I WANT TO RETURN TO
THE RIDICULOUS DOUBLE STANDARD
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS FACING,
THIS TIME IT'S INAUGURATION
FUNDING.
THIS PRACTICE HAS NEVER FALLEN
UNDER SUCH SCRUTINY BUT THIS
SUPPOSE THAT BLOCKBUSTER
INVESTIGATION GIVES LIBERALS THE
NARRATIVE THAT THE WALLS ARE
CLOSING IN SO THE PRESIDENT HAS
NOWHERE TO TURN.
HERE'S SOMETHING YOU MIGHT NOT
KNOW.
BACK IN 2013 SPECIAL INTERESTS
CONTRIBUTED 40%, THAT'S ALMOST
HALF OF THE FUNDS FOR OBAMA'S
SECOND INAUGURATION.
HERE WITH REACTION THIS ARI
FLEISCHER FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY TO BUSH 43 AND
ROBERT WOLF.
OBAMA MAKE A DONOR AND SOMEONE
WHO DONATED MONEY TO THE 2012
INAUGURATION FOR BARACK OBAMA.
IS THIS SCRUTINY WARRANTED?
IS THIS A CLEAR-CUT CASE OF A
DOUBLE STANDARD?
>> ON THE SURFACE IT CERTAINLY
SEEMS TO BE A DOUBLE STANDARD.
THE INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY WAS
NEVER A REAL INVESTIGATION OF
HER AND THAT IS TROUBLING.
I DON'T LIKE TO DRAW CONCLUSIONS
LIKE THAT ABOUT JUSTICE AND I
WAS RAISED TO BELIEVE JUSTICE IS
BLIND BUT WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
JUSTICE.
THESE WERE LEAKS INTO THE
NEWSPAPER, IT'S NOT YET
CONFIRMED.
IF THE FOCUS IS ON FOREIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS AND GIVEN TO
STRONGMEN WHO DONATED, THAT IS A
DIFFERENT MATTER AND IT SHOULD
BE INVESTIGATED BUT I HAVEN'T
SEEN ANY EVIDENCE THAT ANY WOODY
IN TRUMP DID ANYTHING WRONG.
>> Laura: ROBERTS, YOU WERE A
BIG DONOR TO PRESIDENT OBAMA, I
THINK CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS ARE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO GIVE AS
MUCH MONEY AS YOU WANT TO ANYONE
AND YOUR OWN MONEY SHOULDN'T
MATTER.
ANYBODY SHOULD BE ABLE TO GIVE
WHATEVER THEY WANT, I HAVE NO
PROBLEM YOU'RE A BIG DONOR TO
OBAMA.
HE SWORE OFF SPECIAL INTERESTS
IN THE FIRST INAUGURATION BUT
THEN TOOK CORPORATE MONEY,
LOBBYIST MONEY, TEACHERS UNIONS,
ALL SORTS OF UNION MONEY AND
CAME TO THE CAMPAIGN.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE HERE?
>> WE SHOULD TAKE A STEP BACK.
I THINK YOUR PREMISE IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD OTHERWISE
GEORGE W. BUSH TOOK FROM THE
SAME TYPE OF PEOPLE.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CORPORATE MONEY HERE, I
THINK THE POINT IS WHETHER
FOREIGN INTERESTS WHO GAVE?
IF YOU WANT TO GO BACK WHERE
CORPORATE INTERESTS STARTED I
THINK IN 2005 IN THE
INAUGURATION, HE TOOK FROM THE
SAME PEOPLE THAT GEORGE W. BUSH
TOOK FROM.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT
CORPORATE, I THINK IT'S ABOUT
WERE ANY LAWS BROKEN?
I'M NOT SAYING ANY LAWS WERE
BROKEN, I'M SAYING I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT.
>> Laura: IT'S A COMPLETE
FISHING EXPEDITION I'M GOING TO
TELL YOU WHY.
HILLARY CLINTON FOUNDATION
RECEIVED MONEY FROM
SAUDI ARABIA, KUWAIT, QATAR,
OMAN, AUSTRALIA, NORWAY,
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC, I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH ALGERIA GAVE AND
SUDDENLY ALL THAT MONEY STARTS
DRYING UP WHEN SHE IS NO LONGER
THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND SHE'S
NO LONGER CLEARLY GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES -- ALL THAT MONEY
WENT AWAY.
DO YOU THINK THAT MONEY WAS
DONATED TO GET ACCESS?
CAN YOU IMAGINE DONORS GET
ACCESS IN THE OBAMA WORLD AND
ALL THESE PEOPLE GOING TO THESE
PARTIES -- THEY AREN'T GETTING
ACCESS!
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE WHY PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO CONTINUE TO GET
ACCESS AND WHY DID THEY STOP
GIVING MONEY?
OF COURSE.
YOUR GUEST MADE THE POINT ABOUT
THE HOTEL.
SOMETHING THAT'S UNUSUAL AND
DIFFERENT ABOUT DONALD TRUMP, TO
HIS CREDIT THAT SHE'S A
BUSINESSMAN.
HE CAME FROM A HOTEL INDUSTRY.
ALL THE LAWS AND ALL THE RULES
ARE SET UP TO MAKE IT EASY FOR
CAREER POLITICIANS TO STAY IN
CONGRESS AND STATE AND
GOVERNMENT AND THEREFORE YOU
NEVER HAD A CONFLICT BECAUSE YOU
DON'T OWN ANYTHING IN THE REAL
WORLD.
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM
TO RUN AND PEOPLE TRY TO MAKE A
MOUNTAIN OUT OF NOTHING.
HE'S ALREADY SAID HE'S NOT
MAKING THE PROFITS FROM IT, HE'S
DIVORCED FROM THAT AS THE
PRESIDENT BUT SO WHAT IF THAT
TRUMP CORPORATION IS MAKING
MONEY?
IT IS AMERICA'S PRIVATE SECTOR
AND I WANT PEOPLE FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO BE ABLE TO RUN
FOR OFFICE.
>> I'M ALL FOR CAPITALISM.
I RAN A BANK THAT'S IN 49
STATES, WE GAVE TO THE RNC, WE
GAVE TO THE DNC, PHIL GRAMM WAS
MY VICE CHAIRMAN.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
DONALD TRUMP DOING AMAZINGLY
WELL.
UBS DID BUSINESS WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
WERE TALKING ABOUT TODAY, DID
THE INAUGURATION COMMITTEE DO
SOMETHING ILLEGAL OR NOT?
LET ME JUST FINISH.
>> THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
SPENDING MONEY AT HIS HOTEL.
>> AM I SAYING ANYTHING IS WRONG
WITH THAT?
I'M SAYING THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT.
>> Laura: YOU RAISED IT MANY
TIMES.
>> I RAISED IT BECAUSE IT WAS ON
THE FRONT PAGE.
>> Laura: HOW'D THAT HAPPEN TO
COME OUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
INAUGURAL COMMITTEE ITSELF --
THEY'VE NEVER HEARD OF ANY
INVESTIGATION.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ASKED FOR
DOCUMENTS AND HAVEN'T BEEN
INTERVIEWED AND SUDDENLY THIS IS
LEAKING OUT OF THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
THEY ARE THE MOST LEAKY FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR OFFICE IN THE COUNTR
COUNTRY.
>> THEY WERE OUTSIDE MY OFFICE
FOR FIVE YEARS.
>> Laura: STEPHANIE WALCOTT,
HER COMPANY WAS PAID A LOT OF